the news is crazy isn't it where we have
two news channels in America to tell you
two completely different news how the
hell did that happen just tell me the
news tell me the story I don't want your
spin or your bias thank God we don't do
that with the weather
wouldn't that be insane if we had
political opinionated weather
like Hey we're going to the beach
tomorrow let's check the left-wing
weather
hey folks 90 degrees outside beautiful
day for an abortion
we got some dark clouds coming in excuse
me clouds of color and uh
[Applause]
as you can see we got tropical storm
Kelly of Brewing slowly transition to
Hurricane Kevin but we don't judge and
uh
we're not sure what the future holds but
we know it's female back to you they
them holy moly is just trying to get the
goddamn weather that was weird I got
nothing out of that all right let's
check the right wing weather maybe
that'll be a little more informative the
right wing weather
hey folks grab your boots it's 100
chance of storming the capital
oh yeah gonna be a lot of hailing and
hiling out there and uh
we got some ice in the midwest we need
some ice at the border I'll tell you
that right now and
uh grab your coats because we hate
snowflakes
praise the Lord and back to you sugar
tits
[Applause]
all right but you guys are a great crowd
some people get so offended by these
jokes the gay joke the Puerto Rican joke
I got yelled at by a guy recently on the
show this guy comes up and goes hey
buddy I'm gay and Puerto Rican all right
I don't appreciate those jokes you know
how hard my life is I was like whoa take
it easy how hard your life is dude you
have the most parades
[Music]
ah
yeah yeah I don't know race is always
such a touchy issue we're all so
uncomfortable to our race these days you
know especially white people we're all
scared of looking racist that's a big
fear we have like I was talking to one
guy in my last day job and I was like
hey man what's the name of that new guy
on the fifth floor the really tall black
guy and this guy goes whoa
[Laughter]
see color
like really did you really just say that
that really just come out of your face
so I looked this guy right in the eye
and I was like hey man it's cool
I'm black
and he was like no you're not and I'm
like
[Music]
oh yeah you may not be racist but you
are a liar
oh boy I'll tell you I was the uh I was
the victim of racism recently I should
tell you I love Jewish women that's my
number one love the Jewish any Jewish
gals here
all right hey Shalom
um
love Jewish women I was actually lucky
enough to date a Jewish girl for a while
we talked about getting married and her
dad made us break up because I'm not
Jewish
and I was like come on really seriously
like I live in New York I have curly
hair I'm circumcised I'm a comedian I'm
like right there
oh but still still he was like no no my
daughter will only marry a Jew I want my
people to live on I want my culture to
live on Jews are all about living on
that's when I thought man Jews must be
really jealous of gay people
because gay people can't even reproduce
yet they keep popping up
like you got to marry you got to marry
Jew and gays are like
we'll be fine
all right you guys are a fun crowd you
know a lot of crowds now very sensitive
everybody's so offended these days words
I always get jealous when people get
offended they go hey that joke offended
me I'm like wow I wish I cared about
anything as much you cared about that
joke
what's it like to feel
the only feeling I really get is
loneliness I feel very lonely as a guy
who doesn't get offended a fan of people
like get together they make signs they
protest I don't feel we don't get
together never see a bunch of unoffended
people outside of a university like huh
yeah but I don't look where it's gotten
us the whole country feels angry we're
all pent up we got white supremacists
protests all the time hate groups now
you're allowed to be hateful in America
as long as you're not specific you know
if you go I hate Jewish people everybody
goes oh my God what a bigot Prejudice
but if you go I hate people everybody
goes tell me about it
hey
oh yeah people are angry man I had one
of those uh White lives matter rallies
go by my house the other day I freaked
out then I realized ah it's just a half
marathon
[Applause]
I think my weirdness has hurt me with
the with the gals I'm seeing somebody
now but uh boy I was a bad dater I uh I
went on a blind date once right when the
girl saw me she goes hey I bet we'd have
really cute kids I was like all right I
bet we'd have great sex and she goes
whoa slow down
I was like it's like slow down you're
nine months ahead of me
I don't know I will say this one thing I
learned I'm sick of good looking people
I'm done with you men and women you know
you think everything you say is
interesting I went on a date with a girl
once she was gorgeous way out of my
league beautiful woman but she had
nothing to say boring no personality and
I kind of checked out at one point and
she goes look I can tell you I don't
like me just want to sleep with me and I
was like well yeah but that's your fault
she was like screw you I'm more just a
pretty face I'm like but that's all you
worked on
hours on your hair makeup outfit get a
funny knock knock joke together
I don't get these good-looking people
they spend 100 of their time on their
looks zero on their personality you just
assume that part's amazing why would you
have to work on that too all right like
I know I'm not a hot guy before a date
I'm writing jokes in my hand limericks
anecdotes I'm bringing it baby I'm tap
dancing out there yeah
yeah
like you know
if a girl told me hey Mark you're funny
but you're not that hot I'll be like I
know that's why I'm funny
to fill in the gaps here you know
but when you're single you miss love
love is good you want somebody to love
you you know but that's the thing we all
want the love part but nobody wants to
do the work we just want the love nobody
wants to call you and check and get
yelled at we want the love part yeah
it's kind of like a dog walker we all
love our dog be a pacemind do the stuff
you don't want to do pick up the poop
walk it wouldn't be great to have a
girlfriend Walker
just some guy on the sidewalk walking
eight girls like all right
tell me about your day
hey girl yeah
yeah
get angry at me about a dream you had
tell me you're not mad when you clearly
are all right cry now cry now right then
you get your girlfriend back like did
she cry took a while but she cried
thanks a lot I'm Kevin Hart
[Music]
mother